hansa vor zu liefern das sind doch die
scheidungen der ukraine und bei der nato
der ganzen kritik an der regierung wegen
verantwortlich getroffen damit
deutsch die deutsche politik ist davon
bundesregierung versteht ja und es geht
das bedeutet auch dass wir unsere
russische präsident putin sich wirklich
schönen guten tag gesagt manchmal kann
natürlich können viele dinge passieren
zahlreiche unterstützung schon geleistet
getroffen dass es jetzt wichtig wir sind
wirklich gelungen ist den verbündeten
abgestimmt erfolgt wichtig und deswegen
wochen augen haben und ausland wir haben
dass in der die nato noch wir auch als
gehen wir da auch sehr sehr maßvoll
offen wie jetzt auch darüber reden
wochen des krieges nämlich das schnelle
ein antrag auf mitgliedschaft in der
werden außerdem wir müssen dafür sorgen
reaktion erhalten ich habe heute
dazu führen dass ein anderer hat ein
prinzessin diana von haben schreibt auf
eine ganz große rolle aber der druck auf
was von seiten der ukraine gefordert
neuerdings berichte über diese
konferenz hat klar gezeigt dass die
also der gepard ist vor langer zeit noch
tag diese prüfung etwas gewichen ist
und noch viel mehr zur verfügung stellen
geprägt dass wir keine alleingänge
das ja alles noch überhaupt nicht in
gemeinsam das ist unsere stärke und das
gewährleistet ist dass wir nicht zur
wir waren von anfang an da sehr klar und
schwer verkalkuliert hatte
direkt nach washington zu unserer us
auf das material eine geringere
ausbildung auf moderne alarmsysteme in
gemeinsamen anstrengungen verdoppeln
die an schwersten wo es am schwersten
vorstöße nicht möglicherweise
youtube wie wirkt sich die heutige
können und das einsortieren können dass
druck extern und intern
tatsächlich dann das was dann gut genug
unter einem enormen druck und unter
drittes land der leidtragende ist und
des zögerlichen handelns dem kanzler
noch einmal ein paar ganz schöne
stünde die tür offen
guten tag es ist ein wichtiger tag und
in bezug auf panzerfäuste in bezug auf
wir sind live mit zdf heute live und das
sicht und das deutschland der
machen dass wir uns eng abstimmen mit
immer um die lieferung schwerer waffen
deutsch 23 werden das hätte verheerende
das können wir nicht alles vorher sagen
welche mit hilfe erwarten sie nun von
damit um die entscheidung sehr
youtube endlich liefern wir und da noch
nato stellen wird aber das dauert noch
deutlich gemacht dass wir genau da wo
nächsten wochen für die ukraine von
kriegspartei aber dennoch ganz deutlich
gewünscht wird das prüfen wir
entscheidung auf die zukunft aus liefern
die geschlossenheit war von anfang an
hatte die ganze zeit auch gespürt die
verständnis kommen was für die
ja die regierung spricht das nicht so
ukrainischen soldaten auch noch
übergriffe gehört die ursachen werden
unterstützen dass man mit dem gepard
müssen um die ukraine langfristig
durchhaltefähigkeit bei der ukraine und
lass uns noch mal festhalten
kann was auch bedeuten wird aus meiner
das natürlich ein versuch von erpressung
ist und damit hätten wir dann auch die
unseren alliierten und genau gemacht zug
korrespondentin claudia bates von der
nachhaltigen erfolg bringen aber ich
was wärst du diese antwort empfunden
die bundesregierung der kam nicht nur
bezug auf die ausbildung und bezug auf
dass eben das ansehen von deutschland
ein zweites kalt krieges entwickelt
unmissverständlich
deutschland liefert seit kriegsbeginn
zugeständnisse ja aus dem rücken zu
entscheidender bedeutung sind wir müssen
der hinweis von mir ihr könnt uns
wirklich nie dagewesener kritik in der
fortwährend und treffen dann eben auch
sicherheit der ukraine erforderlich ist
ausbilden wird hier in deutschland damit
was ihr gerade gesehen habt das war die
ist sie zu bedienen wo man am meisten
aber es ist einfach nicht hilfreich und
ist
folgen das müssen wir brechen dann eine
geleistet werden das steht auch genau
identifiziert worden ist was die ukraine
flugabwehr deswegen hier unterstützen
wir weiter oder geht die diskussion dann
ukraine steht nicht allein sondern sie
international so viel schaden nimmt wie
worden um tatsächlich flugzeuge in einer
der bundesregierung und diese gefahr
und ich denke dass spekulation jetzt
insbesondere ein bisschen jetzt sind
sicht dass man wahrscheinlich an das
um zug mit unseren alliierten
von den internationalen partnern wurde
aufzustellen und ich freue mich auf die
für die usa ein ganz ganz wichtiges
der westen ist jetzt im wort das
wir uns natürlich auch gerne die
das sind dann jetzt lieferungen aus
russland sollte es einfach schwer
die panzerhaubitze 2000 durch die lieder
außenminister lawrow hat ja auch von
unterstützen wir haben die entscheidung
offen aus wie wir es auch gerade vom
die entsprechenden entscheidungen das
also schritt halten mit der kriegs
frage von sabina zweier
lernen muss dass er doch auch die die
ein sehr konstruktiver tag
damit wir himmel und erde in bewegung
natürlich gerne eure fragen und
traue mich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
noch
gefährlich
feiern und dass es gelungen ist
weitere eskalation aber die zahl der
unterstützen deswegen haben wir schon
auf der liste dessen was die ukraine
sie es passiert ist es gab ja auch in
deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte
wieder von vorne los
wird unterstützt von so vielen staaten
kurze pressekonferenz von
noch brauch bei den drohnen bei der
material das zur zeit in der aktiven
der ukraine waffen unterstützung in
pressekonferenz von
sehr geringen reichweite abzuschießen
gemacht werden dass die nachbarn
druck aus dem kessel nimmt
ist deutschland nicht mehr ganz hinten
auszugleichen und das machen wir jetzt
analysiert wir sind noch nicht ganz
element auch weil sie gelernt hatten aus
panzer glauben sie dass eine lieferung
verteidigungsminister gehört haben
kommentare schicken einfach in die
einem
keine einschätzung zu wie weit die
beantwortet die nach den schulungen
die säbel zu rasseln und über einen
noch am meisten hergerichtet werden
immer da wo diese anleger kommt gutes
setzen können die erfordernisse zu
diskussion in dieser monatlichen
er da schon extrem groß sein und darf
verfrüht wären aber
nenne das ist das was wir leisten wo wir
verteidigungsminister osten einschätzen
das ist nicht immer ganz fair aber es
stellvertreterkrieg gesprochen ist das
beständen der industrie nicht aus den
geschwindigkeit und wenn wir heute uns
ganz früh ganz früh aus den beständen
wir hatten sehr viele bereichernde
bei den lieferungen sondern damit ist
waffen geliefert wird ist nicht alleine
bedrohen können und wir müssen sie in
verwendung in
den vergangenen wochen massive kritik
das ist das richtige signal von wegen
braucht und das ist das was wir
mit dem was wir liefern das haben am
gute frage ich hoffe dass die diskussion
müssen kann das vielleicht doch
gepard das machen wir aber auch in bezug
deutschland sei ein großartiger freund
live und gehen direkt rüber nach
der kann im prinzip auch möglicherweise
ausreicht was meinen sie
ja das ähnlich äußert sich ja auch
gefragt haben wir sind hier und haben
das werden glaube ich die nächsten
kontaktgruppe
deutschland dieses zugeständnis
nicht vergessen die zwei us minister für
erfüllen
deutschland plötzlich ziemlich vorne
luftsicherung bei der flugabwehr dass
bei der bundeswehr und auch bei anderen
der bundeswehr geliefert was möglich war
uns einbringen und wir werden weiter mit
beständen der bundeswehr richtig na ja
irgendwie einer einem
anfang mit leichten waffen gemacht jetzt
lassen wollen
abgestimmt mit anderen jetzt möglich
entscheiden darauf an dieser verbund
unter anderem des ukrainischen botschaft
tatsächlich die aktuelle russische sicht
in diesem konflikt ist es doch so
einem sehr hohen maß da haben wir aus
jetzige offensive tatsächlich
anliegen identifiziert wird in
ist auf jeden fall ein fakt und das ist
solchen möglichen einsatz von atomwaffen
dem chaotischen abzug aus afghanistan wo
auch als bundeskanzler scholz bei
sicher aber natürlich bleiben wir
auf drohnen in bezug auf panzer hat
verabschieden sind wir entschlossener
dabei damit liefert deutschland
ramstein zur pressekonferenz von
der us airbase in ramstein in rheinland
drohen abschließend ein bisschen von der
stunden und tage zeigen das was
abzuringen das ist wirklich bestimmt mit
gespräche den ganzen tag über unter den
die adresse mailen die jetzt gerade
claudia die usa haben gesagt sie wollen
machen wir das mit schweren waffen wenn
immer wieder kontroverse meinungen dann
den verbündeten darüber sprechen was
streitkräften ist wahrscheinlich
erfolgreich ist und das muss man ja auch
nicht jedes mal wieder von vorne losgeht
wir genau da entscheidungen getroffen
außen und für verteidigung die waren ja
dieser fähigkeit schwächen
sie meinen die us die
machen so gehen wir auch weiterhin einen
dass in deutschland melnik und das ist
aus russland im vorfeld des treffens
das sind alte bundeswehr panzer die
größe ab er ist allerdings auch nicht
noch einmal herzlichen dank an alle
da geht es um panzerfäuste da ging es um
abstimmung mit unseren partnern genau so
zu spekulieren herzlichen dank mehr zeit
oder würden sie das auch in die
ursula von der leyen was eine eine
plötzlich mehr als andere eu partner und
den beständen der bundeswehr geliefert
präsident beiden dann als schwach
gedanken im kanzleramt geben dass man
eingeblendet wird
irgendwann eingreifen muss und das zur
vor allen dingen auf die kommunikation
sozusagen die erste reaktion der presse
denn je die ukraine zu unterstützen in
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht
haben und es ist auch positive reaktion
himmel und erde in bewegung setzen um
verantwortlichen und jetzt möchte ich
etwas anderes zur verfügung stehen würde
gerade in kiel von herrn mit präsident
hier auch fokussiert wir wollen
präsident biden war hat der auch im
noch mehr geht und mittel- und
möchte ich die von frank vielleicht auf
werden in bezug auf panzerfaust wir
pfalz da findet heute ein treffen statt
einfach zu bedienen weil hier geht es
der größte brocken heute
schublade propaganda anordnen
eu-mitgliedschaft angeht das klingt nach
es gibt hinweise dass wir weiter liefern
sagen der erfolg der offensive kann ja
drohungen im staatsfernsehen sagt
wieder zurückgegangen sind sozusagen an
ja auch in der ausladung von präsident
staaten die heute hierhin gekommen sind
62 tage krieg liegen jetzt hinter uns
gehen wir auch in zukunft vor die
verfügung stellen muss denn so viel wie
darauf sein wird ich meine einschätzung
ich habe noch eine andere frage hier
kritisch
wäre das gut aber das ist das was ich
wahrgenommen wurde und als jemand der
facebook noch vorlesen deutschland macht
eben auch schwere waffen das war ja
der bundesregierung und zurückzuführen
langfristig müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
sei denn zugesprochen und präsident
nicht nur darum mit einer kanone um sich
vielleicht diesen krieg doch gar nicht
das ist alles geliefert worden immer in
habe für diese pressekonferenz nicht
er in diesem kreise bestimmt zu sagen
grunde die kritiker in der
schön schreibt auf youtube auf in das
die gelegenheit ergreifen um allen
vereinbarungen mit der industrie
die industrie diese zum teil zehn jahre
zu dem die usa eingeladen haben
ihrer bekämpfung der russischen
steinmeier geändert der ja eigentlich
eben skizziert habe und man muss sich im
die ukraine im kampf gegen russland zu
außenminister lavrov waffenlieferungen
haben das fortwährend getan seit dem tag
ich habe jetzt nicht gehört wer hier
was muss passieren damit dieser konflikt
beeinflusst werden nämlich dadurch dass
das handelsblatt berichtet heute über
sich nicht allzu gut mit den partnern
bisher auch bei frankreich bei in
pressekonferenz direkt im keim erstickt
so schnell doch gar nicht unbedingt
zu schießen sondern es geht auch darum
soll man sagen so viel material steht
die ukraine über eine gut ausgebildete
oder eben auf die nicht kommunikation
ist dass das nicht wahnsinnig viel
dass der luftraum gesichert wird dass
natürlich ein solches
drin die ich ihnen auch gerne direkt
selensky hat die gebeten mit deutschland
das war eine ganz wichtige arbeit und
rät zwischen russland und der ukraine
mehr als es letztlich ist denn solche
grunde genommen sehr genau überlegen was
getroffen die ukraine bestellt wir
eingeräumt wir danken ihnen sehr für
aggression der russischen gräueltaten
würden öl ins feuer gießen und warnt vor
abstimmung und genauso werden wir auch
mit dem rat den wir hier im hintergrund
stellvertreter für wen sein soll also
zurzeit in den garagen nicht rum dass
wir haben bis gestern oder eigentlich
eins das ist unser weg zu prüfen zu
alt die sind alle
eine bevorstehende entscheidung zur
nach kiew reisen wollte hast du jetzt
verantwortung für weitere tote
schon mal sehr toll dass man direkt hier
und hat gesagt deutschland er hätte
man die ukrainerin daryna unterstützt
italien nicht so also ich glaube wenn
verteidigungsministerium
vertreterinnen und vertreter mehrerer
unterstützen das sind natürlich große
übergreifen eines konflikts auf ein
ihre teilnahme
freiraum bringt und den druck noch nicht
mit den verbündeten koordiniert hatte
und gut ausgestattete an den verfügt wir
gewinnen möchte für die ukraine sondern
prozesse sind eben doch lang und die
gepanzerten schon besucht
nach den jetzigen lieferungen union
weitermachen zug um zug das was die
zu reden also hat sich quasi um der
instandsetzungs bedürftig also das geht
man nutzbar machen könnte und deswegen
man versucht ja immer wieder
sehen das ziel tatsächlich zu finden und
verteidigungsministerin danken
einem dritten weltkrieg ob bosch muss
putin muss diese entscheidung fällen er
fragen stellen kann danke zdf ja aber
zivilisten tragen deutschland und der
hier aktiv erklärt werden kann es ist
das war ein machtvolles signal
bezahlen die ertüchtigung initiative
und hier wirklich versucht den
länder nehmen teil und wo es im prinzip
worte denen jetzt auch taten folgen
nachbarland nicht und wir müssen alles
absolutes vertrauen zu deutschland das
lieferung von leopard-2-panzern
dass man
darzustellen ich
und wir wollen alle noch mehr tun als
aus der regierung heraus nimmt weil man
ja das war die pressekonferenz von
und das wollte man diesmal ganz anders
vermittlungsrolle gebeten zwischen tier
bis heute früh im ard morgenmagazin noch
entscheiden in der abstimmung mit
werden unseren teil dazu beitragen keine
schon reaktionen aus der ukraine mit
jetzt nicht sofort manche kann man
die gefahr ist ernst man darf sie nicht
ist die frage sind wir bereit diesen
ukraine braucht und das was mit unseren
vielleicht möchte dass russland nicht
kommt auch die geparden werden
insbesondere auch dem ukrainischen
deutschland ist ein großer freund ein
vorstellung dass ein kriegs land in die
versuche jetzt mal das sozusagen den die
wird aufgestockt auf zwei milliarden wir
wir werden auf der basis dieses
es sicher zum schießen aber man muss
jetzt sogar noch im bundestag die unions
westen zünden am dritten weltkrieg was
deutschland das richtige tun werde und
sehr gerne geschehen aber ihr könnt
waffenlieferungen und der einsatz der
schneller liefern andere kann man andere
müssen würdest du sagen dass es ihnen
machen und wirklich eine ganz ganz große
kriegsverlauf denn das wollen wir tun
unseren alliierten 2
das ist jetzt eine medien quelle aber
uns ein anliegen genau da immer
darum geht wie man die ukraine
in der uns in macht stehende tun dass
ja das muster möglicherweise erkennen
von berlin die zwei amerikaner und das
möglicherweise irgendwann im gefecht
verteidigungsminister
gehört deutschland kann überhaupt keine
unterschätzen
alliierten zusammen möglich ist und wir
hat es begonnen es war ungerechtfertigt
weiter eure fragen stellen in den
schritt zu gehen ist eine politische
waffen ob das funktionieren wird die
bekommen auf diese neue nachricht dass
bisher wir wollen unsere anstrengungen
fraktion zustimmt dass dann die
immer sagen in der jetzigen situation
fortschritts von heute weiter arbeiten
eu eintritt oder in die nato das ist
ganz in die decke gedrückt wird das habe
wichtiger verbündeter und ich habe
den kriegsverlauf zu beeinflussen wir
geschlossene front präsentieren und dazu
anzusetzen wo die ukraine den bedarf
gelungen mit diesem treffen
gleichzeitig hat man aber auch den
verbindung zu konstruieren die er
streitkräfte angeht das her da hat es
haben den ringtausch jetzt initiiert um
kann dass immer wieder erst sehr spät
es wird ein bisschen dauern bis die dann
wenn man so ein bisschen in die
die us regierung hat deutlich gemacht
wie würden sie auf so ein kommentar
panzer liefern weil wir haben keine oder
kommentarspalten reinschreiben oder eben
ist dann schon enorme druck auf der auf
werden uns auch weiter einbringen
unterstützen kann auch nach dem krieg
die ukraine erfolg hat und ich glaube
nicht mehr verwendbar sein deswegen ist
logistik und die ausbildung an solchen
es ist besser etwas zu haben was man
debatte die man im grunde und heute
ich heute gelesen bei einem cdu csu
möglicherweise im kopf gehabt hat in den
und sehen dass wir noch weitere
auch besser koordinieren
und anlasslos und es ist an ihm
eindruck und auch sozusagen hinter den
verteidigungsminister und seine
wollen dass die ukraine in diesem
wieder instand gesetzt wurden aber es
reagieren ja ich glaube deutschland
bundesregierung so sage ich mal auf der
nun jetzt auch dieser gepa panzer
sieht wo die ukraine den bedarf hat in
beispielsweise in kooperation mit unser
und auch viel internationalen druck hin
koalition rein hört und ein bisschen
meinen militärdienst hier in deutschland
wir haben keine munition oder wir haben
dort wo systeme außer wird beständen
diente auch dieses treffen und hat
per mail schicken
führen muss wenn man morgen in der lage
es jetzt gut sich ein plan zu machen was
das ist der beste weg auch diesem thema
dass sie einen sieg der ukraine für
letzten wochen
waffensystemen vorzunehmen sollte nicht
us airforce es außerhalb der vereinigten
generell wollte hat zum beispiel gesagt
delegation waren
schwer vorstellbar dass heißt es gibt ja
der bundesregierung lastet wenn die
sehr viele verluste gegeben von
gepaart panzer geliefert werden sollen
kulissen und auch jenseits der
konflikt mit erfolgreich vom
verteidigungsexperten
wir sind ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
gleichgesinnte staaten finden wir werden
vielleicht nur in anfängen bedienen kann
taucht immer wieder die die idee auf
deutschland liefert ich glaube die frage
abstimmung mit unseren partnern in der
andreas
sein will tatsächlich der ukraine klar
ja nach meinem eindruck schon der
möglich hält die nächsten wochen seien
keine möglichkeiten die ukraine an
amerikaner sagen wir möchten euch bitte
trägt keine verantwortung an zivilen
wenn auch das russische material
gehört auch wie zufrieden die bisherigen
fachlichen ebene ein bisschen aufatmen
unterschätzt werden außerdem müsse diese
geht hier jetzt um panzer die diese
sicher diesen eindruck auch verstärkt
neues freunden oder auch mit den
regierungsebene analysten experten
die entscheidung zu treffen zu
gerecht zu werden was war nochmal ihre
ganz klare grundlagen dafür die erfüllt
das wird eine spannende diskussion die
noch vorhanden sind dass diese schnell
substantiellen natur auf russischer
also ich habe geguckt und noch keine
staaten
ist tatsächlich der befreiungsschlag
eiskalt erwischt worden weil eigentlich
verbraucht ist was wir dann im grunde
in der ukraine nun entscheidend
schlachtfeld gehen kann im kriege und
niederländern in bezug auf die
abgeleistet und habe mit deutschen
rüstungsfirma gehören und die
denkst du denn dass wenn der
unseren panzern auszubilden deutschland
nato in der eu und darüber hinaus und
weiterhin intransparenz und weil ich mit
ausrichten von der regierung in kiew das
das ging ja darum was tun wir jetzt das
ziel sicher ankommen das war ja auch
in aussicht zu stellen wie man sie
dass russland eigentlich sich ein
kann und sich zugute schreiben kann dass
und nicht perfekt ist als wenn man gar
deeskalieren und das ganze zu stoppen
dass er auch weitere abstimmungs
sie zu sehen
kritiker heute konkret heute sind dann
zweite frage
in die ukraine geliefert werden damit
opfern das sehe ich nicht ich habe
ausbildung pizzen beispielsweise trendy
wenn man so einen haben will da muss ja
verteidigungsminister hat ja auch gerade
äußern sich doch immer wieder sehr
seite sie haben auch sehr viel gerät
sein müssen damit ein land in die nato
sollte diese pressekonferenz erst um
gefunden und ich würde mal sagen das ist
bundesregierung hat jetzt dieser
weiter militärisch unterstützt und damit
noch an westlichen systemen nach flügen
noch weitergeht und die werden wir hier
amerikanische verteidigungsminister sagt
eines der argumente von kanzler scholz
ja bitte bitte hilfe leisten soll aber
streitkräften zusammengearbeitet und das
verloren
haben alle noch mal einen impuls
nichts hat ich glaube das ist das was
kritisch gegenüber deutschland und
das russland diesen krieg nicht gewinnt
nochmal zusammengefasst in der
sie jetzt dieser forderung nach gegeben
wem wir jetzt weitermachen mit
bisschen mit der nato im krieg völlig
schnell damit bekämpft werden kann
und zurück zum verhandlungstisch zu
unseren partnern und verbündeten
kann keine alleingänge machen wenn
eine gute nachricht
16.30 stattfinden wir haben sie deshalb
oder in die eu eintreten kann und bei
butscher ist ja ein wunderbarer hinweis
tatsächlich nach vorne hin gewendet sein
sie haben sehr viel munition verloren
ich bin auch froh dass diese konferenz
wir haben
viele infos und die wollen wir
rüstungsfirma genehmigt dass sie die
heute auch nicht ganz lösen können aber
ja die gefahr dass putin
da gibt es einige systeme die sowohl
glaube ich oder ahne ich dass es
bekommen etwas zu tun was sie tun
wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt hier sehen
und das sind unsere aufgaben immer
das danach verhandelt werden muss wie es
haben sie auch schon die frage von mika
mechanismen einsetzen möchte
uns das sozusagen so im hintergrund die
macht immer sehr großen spaß mit den
vielleicht kann sich ja auch wenig mal
deutschland schwere waffen schrägstrich
gehen wir hoffen dass das passiert
fragen sich eben ob deutschland nicht
pressekonferenz wäre nun alles wie an
ein startschuss ist ein startschuss auch
das ist in ordnung was deutschland macht
das ist nicht der einzige druck der
und man muss jetzt in aussicht stellen
warum er zuerst gegen die lieferung von
kooperieren und wir werden weiterhin
die fragen sind da und die bleiben
dazu wunderbar muss man hier an frischen
können er ist eine teillösung sie können
könnten und es geht ja deutlich darüber
dieser mutige kampf unterstützt werden
nato oder fallen in die usa versuchen
hat schwere waffen zu liefern was
beantwortet der gefragt hat ob denn
deutschland hergestellt hat mit 1 andere
liefern darf der antrag ist schon im
begriffen dass es gewaltige
aufdröseln und analysieren mit christian
noch direkt mitgenommen und fangen erst
panzer liefert wäre es wie so ein
andere trug der auch extrem groß wurde
andreas würde ich sagen den ich eben
aller offenheit die der ukraine auch in
bord ist und hat neue aktivitäten
dafür dass mittel- und langfristig
zu einem lob durchringen weil das
letzte frage an sie
sie haben sehr viel kombattanten
deutschen partnern zu kooperieren
wie man in zukunft in den nächsten
für einträge sehen mit welcher
vielleicht so atomwaffen greifen könnte
das dann auch hier innerhalb
und um
doch ein etwas unsichere unsicherer
diesen diesen krieg zu beeinflussen und
vielleicht nicht jedes mal so zäh werden
denn weitergeht ist auch klar aber zum
bleiben wird ist natürlich die zeit die
mit diesem panzer nicht zum beispiel
hinaus die usa wollen ja auch und
bekannt ist ob sich weiteres material
waffen war
kann und wir helfen dann beispielsweise
länder in der europäischen union und der
in letzter zeit ist der gewesen aus der
kriegseintritt zu verstehen also diese
jetzt an zu erklären worum es eigentlich
maurizio fragt auf youtube warum setzt
mölling guten tag hämmerling hallo
februar gestellt worden also da sind
weitergeht denn die beste
sicherzugehen dass wir diesen
wochen monaten und jahren die ukraine
brutalität und entgrenzung
das ukrainische militär für die zukunft
wird und dass es vielleicht ein bisschen
andreas kühn us aus unserem
schießen aus dänemark
deutschlands die kritik verstummen wird
wirklich schon ja in der geschichte der
herausforderungen gibt in der ukraine
aufgezählt der unterschiedlichen länder
einfach auf andere panzer schießen dafür
jetzigen zeitpunkt haben wir es
ansonsten noch in den lagern der
kantonist ist in diesem ganzen
solidarität im moment entgegen gebracht
geht normalerweise lassen sich
sechs wochen die deutschland nicht
verloren und die militärische fähigkeit
nato beliefert hat wenn man die zur
klarer kommuniziert wird dass
nun ich habe es bereits mehrfach in der
wollten an dieser stelle ja auch
und die möglicherweise auch angestiftet
die ankündigung von deutschland war
hauptstadtstudio berlin den ich eben
sicherheitsgarantie für die ukraine sind
eigenen ampelkoalition vor allen dingen
ganzen argumente die wir bisher gehört
und wir sind alle sehr entschlossen die
tatsächlich mit einem krieg zu tun in
ist ja nicht gedacht
unterstützen will dann kann ich mir
und ein bisschen zur zur befriedung das
fortschritt auch halten können wollen
russland in diesem krieg eigentlich
ausgemusterten bestände befindet ich
man putin kein ultimatum
sechs wochen zeit vergangen mit ganz
besprechen wie geht es weiter mit der
miteinander insofern die kritik hier ist
darunter natürlich auch in deutschland
verfügung stellen würde dann würde man
bundesrepublik heute ein einschneidender
wird ist es doch klar dass das prozesse
emmerling sie sind experte für
haben die gelten ja seit heute 9 uhr
geliefert hat das wird bleiben das wird
deutschland weiter liefert natürlich
stärken wenn wir uns heute abend
haben
mal mit dem gerät umgehen müssen und das
politikerinnen und politiker er zeit und
wieder unterbrechen musste weil eben die
vergangenheit gesagt dass diese rhetorik
das bedeutet würden sie dennoch sagen
vorstellen dass unsere partner glauben
dem
dort geliefert wird das ist schnelle
beiträgt
wichtig dass sie 50 gepaart systeme
wir das fortführen die konferenz heute
von den drei ausschussvorsitzenden
einzieht und es ist vielmehr eine
ukraine das heißt es ist ein ganz klares
das bringt uns so ein bisschen in dem
tatsächlich nachhaltig die ukraine
vielen diskussionen und auch mit ganz
das militärische gewicht darüber
würde sie noch gerne fragen nach ihrer
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik und
ukraine zu unterstützen und zwar heute
er von jahren als von monaten sind
verabschieden dann sind wir
acht nicht mehr das ist die zeit in der
bei den osteuropäischen partnern bei der
ich glaube auf dem auf dem politischen
pressekonferenz begonnen hat umso mehr
und das wird sicherlich sehr stark
dauert moment noch sind die gefahren
ist schwächer als am anfang und der
tag ist eine wende wie oft hat
also weil man nicht eingreifen will in
sehr deutlich und der ruf hat schaden
sind eher ein bisschen später dran wir
unterstützung darum geht dass deswegen
doch sehr
liefern und das ist eine schöne stärkung
hofreiter für europa strack-zimmermann
streitkräfte das ist eine
viel krieg in der ukraine bis jetzt
signal der geschlossenheit aller es ist
dass deutschland tatsächlich verstanden
bleiben die bedenken die es gibt vor
unterstützen können die soldaten müssten
bereich der desinformation denn ich
forschungsdirektor bei der deutschen
wahrgenommen als fortschritt denn auch
einschätzung zu dem interview das der
wird zu einer monatlichen kontaktgruppe
historische verantwortung deutschlands
und die stärke für die zukunft
entscheidet wer nachher welche
entschlossener denn je der ukraine
der russische außenminister hat eine
unnütz und auch gefährlich ist niemand
ukraine langer vielleicht immer ein
insofern sind dass im moment ganz ganz
die eilmeldung kam dass deutschland
deutschland gesagt wir liefern keine
auch nicht da das heißt also das was
danke schön dass du noch bei uns bist
dass diese entscheidung nach der ganzen
herausforderung für die zukunft der
hat was die selbst ausgerufene
sind froh dass wir frau lambrecht noch
nicht ständig um lernen das ist
meine ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile
für verteidigung und michael roth für
wir sind ein verlässlicher partner an
diese entscheidung getroffen wurde die
den ländern zu helfen die hier von einem
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik das
aufzubauen
waffen in krisengebiete wie oft hat
parkett ja es wird ja in dieser woche
hier in den usa war deutschland sehr
heute angekündigt ist ist das umfeld ist
genommen und die frage ist ob man das so
diese panzer liefern wird und von dieser
den krieg also wer sollte putin das
der militärischen kapazitäten nun der
allen dingen in der
austausch ist gar nicht so einfach
niemanden mehr der er glaubt dass die
verhandlungspositionen am
ein ganz klares signal dass diese
zeitenwende ist und sich um die
rechtzeitig erwischt haben es ging im
spd-bundestagsfraktion man darf ja nicht
natürlich auch was auch immer zeit
wichtige und große gesten der
ausgeweitet zum stand der ukraine und
müssen wir uns annehmen und es ist gut
andreas das war jetzt eigentlich schon
beizustehen und herzlichen dank haben
warnung ausgesprochen er hat gesagt es
und wir befinden uns in einer neuen
kritik an der regierung jetzt dieses
kritikpunkt bleiben an deutschland der
diese koalition gesagt wir wollen keine
verhandlungstisch hat vielen dank für
der seite der ukraine mit unseren
kritisiert worden für ein zögerliches
also sehr spät fällt aber als kehrtwende
aufgegeben hat der ja von einer realen
heißt sie sind heute genau der richtige
ultimatum setzen wenn die die nato
will ein atomkrieg ein solcher krieg ist
kostet zum jetzigen zeitpunkt müssen wir
morgen im bundestag eine
außen für auswärtiges die haben doch
geschlossenheit auch in der zukunft
sicherheit europas kümmert zum jetzigen
vergessen in dieser fraktion sitzen
wird dauern aber ich glaube es ist sehr
solidarität auf der praktischen ebene
aufgrund der sanktionen und aufgrund der
dass dieses signal auch von dieser
aggressor überfallen werden das ist
entscheidung sind ja auch wirklich die
schweren waffen liefern also da ist
diese schweren waffen zu liefern
ukraine und was deutschland noch weiter
in kauf nehmen muss für die haltung die
könnte einen dritten weltkrieg geben und
prinzip bei dieser pressekonferenz jetzt
mann für uns und können wir vielleicht
erstaunlich dass der
computing krank und umsetzen weil wenn
alliierten zusammen bei ihnen schon eine
uns noch viele monate vielleicht jahre
ihre informationen und ihre
sie fragen ja eine erste frage an sie
zeitpunkt zweifel unsere partner
ukraine diesen krieg irgendwie begonnen
debatte geben die insofern mit spannung
wichtig diese längere perspektive jetzt
weitergeführt werden soll dafür gibt es
konferenz heute ausgeht von den letzten
ist das nichts was sehr schnell
gefahr eines dritten weltkrieges
die regierung vertritt oder ob wir es
in der bisherigen ukraine politik
das ist eine methode für die
nicht nur die lehre aus der deutschen
handeln auch für die argumente die dafür
phase auf dem schlachtfeld präsident
sagen wir haben zurzeit wahrscheinlich
heute wirklich ein ganz großer schritt
darum dass deutschland sich entschieden
die erste frage beantworten die
einschätzungen christian nerlinger nach
viele abgeordnete die waffenlieferungen
inzwischen auch eine mediale präsenz
verteidigungsminister nach all der
handelsbeschränkungen die auferlegt
trotzdem auch sowohl politisch bedeutsam
diese frist abgelaufen wäre müsste sie
hätte großartig krieg begonnen hat
beschäftigen wird und was bleiben wird
er hat auch vom einsatz der atomwaffen
macht nun das ist eine souveräne
natürlich daran weil es eben immer
geschichte nie wieder krieg sondern es
endlich mal auf zu machen und die
ja mit die höchsten köpfe die größten
vonstatten gehen würde
jetzt kurzfristig keine besseren
gesprochen hat wie bewerten sie diese
verlust für alle beteiligten und wenn
ja auch klare
verteidigungsministerin sagt der gepard
dem disco tisch sitzen und
gegangen worden und natürlich wird das
hat nun doch schwere waffen zu liefern
ja irgendetwas tun die ukraine kann
selensky hat das am sonntag in kiew sehr
russland sogar selber erklärt das nennt
bezeichnet werden darf
gleichgesinnten staaten die
angeführt wurden und die als eher dünn
jetzt heute gesehen haben da doch ein
gehabt und eine wucht entwickelt in
kritik die wir ja eben vor der
wieder diesen druck braucht man kann
grundsätzlich skeptisch sehen die an wie
wurden und noch mal wir möchten einfach
gesprochen
entscheidung der bundesdeutschen
ist auch die lehre
erwartet wurde als die stimmung im
ist auch
lösungen gut ist wenn man langfristig
klar der ich danke dir sehr für deine
bundesregierung und die partner sich
vorhaben er sagt er zum beispiel dass es
wir schauen einmal kurz rüber nach
anstrengungen zu stärken die dem
sind sie jetzt nicht
dieser panzer sei jetzt genau das was
aussage von ihnen
köpfe der koalitionsfraktionen auch
putin kein ultimatum setzen weil wenn
pressekonferenz
ist als auch militärisch
wir jetzt säbelrasseln
dass deutschland nicht befreit worden
die ukraine auch gut finden auch gut
umdenken stattfindet und die zeitenwende
es nicht krieges nennt es
wahrgenommen wurden nun hat der
an die ukraine und zwar vom typ panzer
vorfeld eigentlich ziemlich aufgeheizt
herzlichen dank herr
ihren forderungen das die
regierung ich möchte da keinerlei
deutlich gemacht
damit wollen wir direkt rüber ins
die
überlegen wie sie nicht nur den nächsten
gute lösung auf die beine stellt ich
also am liebsten dort defensivwaffen
sichergehen dass sie diese fähigkeit
auch vermuten dass die lieferung der
möchte gibt die reale gefahr oder ob es
überrascht worden das hat der
analyse der pressekonferenz von
beistand zu koordinieren und es geht
beunruhigt dass das ganze uns aus den
spezialoperation und das geht nicht
thematisiert hatten an der deutschen
die ukraine brauche würden sie das so
hören und diese gefährliche rhetorik ich
die staaten weltweit
war und die unionsfraktion gesagt hat
das ultimatum abgelaufen ist müsste sie
bundessicherheitsrat entschieden und
empathie die deutschland zeigt oder eben
heißen wir werden aber sicherlich auch
spekulation machen ich möchte einfach
koalition da nicht mehr geschlossen
wenn dieses thema erstmal im feld sind
ramstein dort soll jetzt in wenigen
wäre wenn im zweiten weltkrieg nicht
eine eine monatliche kontaktgruppe geben
gepard panzer ausgerechnet heute erst
verteidigungsminister gesagt deutschland
außenminister ich habe eine doppelte
tagen sollen nächsten wochen und monaten
sich eben auch darauf bezieht es bei
liefern würden es gibt einige ganz
regierung sicher durchaus wohlwollend
us-verteidigungsminister osten und
nicht mehr haben dass sie nicht in
darum die menschen zu töten sondern es
hauptstadtstudio nach berlin zu unserem
über andreas ich darf dich kurz
muss mal ganz praktisch nachfragen wie
außer und man darf nicht vergessen die
unterschreiben
vom typ gepaart und weitere infos dazu
wenn man sich anhört wie zum beispiel
wir stellen einen eigenen antrag wir
eine gefahr gibt oder nicht gibt er hat
kritik hören ich habe schon ein bisschen
haben verstärkt unterstützung zugesagt
auch nicht zeigt im vergleich mit
freigegeben worden ist weil natürlich
händen gleitet und dass es doch zu einer
sei ein großartiger freund und er habe
nur sagen dass alles was ich gesehen
darum dass
die ukraine unterstützen wollen dann
minuten die pressekonferenz von
finde das ist wirklich alles andere als
wenige die so gar überhaupt gar keine
dann können sie eine große hilfe
geht darum sozusagen zu entnazifiziert
geäußert hat so hat er hat nicht so ganz
solle jeden monat also wird darüber
andere länder zu den waffen gegriffen
unterbrechen denn jetzt tritt
läuft so was abkommt ukrainische
spd-fraktionschef mützenich heute früh
frage an sie
ich glaube die ukraine braucht eine
schicke ganz viele grüße nach
zukunft weitere nachbarn bedrängen
anderen ländern
möchten einen antrag für schwere
korrespondenten andreas kienast hallo
was gelesen aus der unionsfraktion wo so
immer gut mit den deutschen zusammen
vor allem russland in der hand
diese monatlichen
würden wir möglicherweise aus diesem ja
diese geberkonferenz in ramstein
hilfreich und ich möchte mich auf eine
möchte noch wissen gibt es aus
die zögerlichkeit das hin und her die
vorschicken
moldau hat ja auch die
darstellen klar ist sie kommen später
cdu/csu-fraktion die ja einen eigenen
um den bedarf der ukraine der steigt zu
im fernsehen noch dafür geworben hat
verteidigungsminister austin vor die
nuklearen konfrontation kommt nun wir
habe in der abstimmung mit dem deutschen
hätten und deutschland militärisch
alles das sind euphemismen das sind
hat andrea maurer
ganze menge dinge das hat sich auch in
könnnen wie sie das mit der ukraine
gearbeitet
gesprochen werden wie man sich weiter
washington bereits pläne zur
andreas
das was wir jetzt sehen ist russland hat
soldaten nach deutschland um daran
stattgefunden hat und jeder irgendetwas
solche diskussion gar nicht einlassen
und die verteidigungsministerin davon
bleibt ja alles und deswegen wird es
wie soll man sagen herr ruckeligen kurs
treffen die können hybrid in präsenz
waffenlieferungen namentliche abstimmung
den letzten wochen immer wieder klar
osten des us verteidigungsministers
verstanden dass deutsche dort geparkt
besiegt hätten und ich glaube dieser
sicherheitsmaßnahmen verstärkt und
ein bisschen die skepsis durchschimmert
intervention wenn die nato an die
kameras und wir übertragen die
größe zurück ja und ich möchte mich auch
koordiniert in der strategie insofern in
getan haben
verteidigungsminister
entsprechen und unser deutscher
als es hätte sein müssen dann über die
nach ramstein bringt die deutsche
ausgebildet zu werden oder umgekehrt
antrag angekündigt hatte für die
weniger auf die militärische logik
widersprüchliche argumentation die
die nächste frage geht an so sang
gemacht
der letzten wochen herauskommen wichtig
tun alles was in unserer macht steht
auf den tisch legen musste das ist die
alles begriffe die verharmlosen was da
und das war ja eigentlich auch so ein
und hatte magath gesagt aber ansonsten
sei er überzeugt würde alles tun was sie
ukraine schwere waffen liefert und
pressekonferenz
frage der lieferung von leopard-panzern
noch uns so schön unterhalten bevor die
seinem anschluss an eine reihe von
teil unserer geschichte ist uns ein
warum haben die jetzt gerade die gitter
man kann mit blick auf die jetzt
und dem verteidigerteam dass sie alles
gastgeber hat eine entscheidung
einen angriffskrieg geführt und
stattfinden wir sehen im moment ist noch
wurde nie einfach werden und vielleicht
oder virtuell stattfinden und es ist ein
sondern mehr auf verhandlungen zu setzen
widersprüchliche kommunikation man nimmt
kommende bundestagssitzung und gesagt
verteidigungsministerin die nachricht
von der ard eine frage von herrn
gerhard vom zdf welche militärhilfe
hat man dann doch irgendwie über das
dynamik solcher konferenzen
an ein brutaler schlag durch russland
der tat ist das sicherlich ein starkes
bisschen als vertrauensfrage gemeint
haben wir quasi seit anfang des krieges
bei euch verabschieden mit einem tipp ja
explosionen in
beschwert sich darüber dass andere dem
pressekonferenz mit
und richtig ist dass die ukraine das
russland beginnt das bündnis anzugreifen
die soldaten also wie wir würden ja
können und natürlich gab es da ja mit
angekündigte lieferung sagen besser spät
bisschen in vergessenheit geraten und es
ist es auch ganz gut dass es nicht
mit dass die bundesregierung die
wie zweifelt er sich noch geäußert hat
hat wir möchten jetzt butter bei die
wir wollen da will keiner mit der
nichts passiert gegen 17 uhr soll die
verteidigungsminister in lambrecht
tut was sie tun kann und dass sie sich
getroffen und ich begrüße die
losgetreten worden ist von daher würde
angegriffenen zu hilfe kommen das ist
signal in alle möglichen richtungen nach
der separatist separatisten regionen
deutschland die empathie für die ukraine
einfach wird vielleicht ist es auch gut
gleiche geredet man muss ja sagen
vertrauensfrage gegen den bundeskanzler
dialog gremium und das hat heute schon
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
als nie die ukraine braucht natürlich
entscheidung der deutschen
gesprochen dh da hätte man schon wenn
losgeht da ist sie uns zuvorgekommen
der jetzigen entscheidung
nicht in der ukraine ausbilden dann
schlechten presse rausgehen und
dass sich ein staat wie deutschland mit
ist sehr schwer zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
fische namentlicher abstimmung wissen
das zdf macht heute abend einen abend
material nicht nur heute und morgen
spangenberg von frau schwang
und auch die ukraine hat diesen ansatz
über die lieferung von panzern
eng abstimmen mit ihren verbündeten und
losgehen und die wollen wir ihnen und
öffentliche kritik aus den usa gab es
verteidigungsminister lambrecht das 50
ich vom russischen außenminister zum
akzeptieren ein paar wenige fragen
man nimmt die der bundesregierung nicht
diese fähigkeit ihren luftraum zu
freigegeben hat mit geparden das ist
ein bisschen kurios ist als eine wii
seiner geschichte so quält in dieser
dementsprechend war auch die
bekommt sondern über die nächsten wochen
damit umzugehen dass wir tatsächlich nur
scholz dies war direkt gegen ihn
innen das ist auch immer wichtig nach
dann muss man sagen ja das ist vor allen
werden wir genau da wo quasi russland
da war die us regierung völlig eindeutig
schön dass wir deshalb jetzt reden
geparkt panzer zu schicken doch eine
wer ist dafür wäre es dagegen und da war
glauben sie dass der konflikt jetzt
man damals gesagt hat okay wir bereiten
jetzigen zeitpunkt auch nichts anderes
bundesregierung unter druck hier etwas
so richtig ab man hat das gefühl in den
euch dann auch zeigen andreas besprechen
der solidarität im hauptprogramm geht
seine stärke bewiesen ich möchte noch
auch bisher nicht oder nur ganz
und monate und gesichert und das heißt
die internationale gemeinschaft ist da
schützen das alleine wird aber nicht
dass sie
gerichtet die union wollte da
sondern sagen
frage aber
china
können ich würde gerne mal auf dieses
auf den tisch zu legen
uns auf alle eventuell fälle vor hätte
russland das ist ganz besonders wichtig
genau das was die ukraine jetzt braucht
ständig schaut was möglich ist und
dingen ein kommunikationsproblem und da
die koalition natürlich jetzt auch
vielleicht auf moldan übergreifen könnte
erwarten als dass er versucht hier
noch vor der wahl stehen diesen ländern
ich werde eventuell nicht moderieren
große veränderung
mit dem finger auf uns zeigen können
osteuropäischen ländern vor allem dass
reichen in der ukraine in der ost
ich habe noch eine detailfrage von einem
auch jetzt schon gleich los in 10
verhalten und die amerikaner waren ja
etwas anderes unterstreichen wir haben
eine sichere ukraine in die zukunft ist
man damals schon klinische soldatinnen
auch dass man von daraus rückrechnung
gezwungen einen eigenen antrag
russische
wir so lange bitte weiter die ampel
aber auch darüber hinaus den usa ist
sagt man schaut kriegseintritt
um den luftraum zu sichern vom boden aus
tatsächlich stimmungsmache nicht zu
auch sehr wachsam
timing noch mal zurückkommen
die usa hat mir zu diesem treffen
stolz in die enge treiben die luft ist
mit gewalt zu helfen alles andere ist
minuten mit einem benefiz spiel borussia
ukraine läuft zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
zweite frage nach dieser großen
man darf eben nichts darf eben nicht
können mangels zeit herzlichen dank
soldaten an den panzer ausbilden können
man deutschland zu dieser position heute
einzubringen und man sieht oder man so
muss man gucken muss man muss sich dann
ja sich nicht an den an den reporter
immer öffentlich sehr sehr höflich und
kampfstiefel über der grenze eines nato
heute uns überlegt wie die langfristige
hause zu machen sondern hier vor allen
inwieweit man die ukrainischen
koalition steht ja wirklich seit wochen
dass es hier noch mal deutlich geworden
auch wichtig dass die westliche welt als
deutschland ausgerechnet auch noch
aber natürlich hilft es jetzt wenn sie
britische regierung hat heute auch
eine russische offensive und wenn sie
user auf youtube gibt es noch genug
so weiter aber ich glaube dass das heute
jetzt nicht mehr möglich aber diese
eingeladen und es ging ja insgesamt um
ausgerechnet heute vor diesem treffen
konferenz über die aufrüstung der
dortmund gegen dynamo kiew und danach
mit der ausbildung beginnen denn das was
nun diese rhetorik über den möglichen
raus also ich habe vorhin gehört was der
dingen im westen zu machen
treiben musste dass deutschland nicht
in der kritik dass dazu wenig passiert
nicht in sicht
deutschland als erstes an die
richtet mit dem er spricht sollen hier
deutschland ist dazu bereit es ist eine
es denkbar dass die ukraine der nato
denn dann irgendwann da sind tatsächlich
ein bisschen dass das auch insofern
geschlossen wahr genommen wird dass die
zugesichert dass
unterstützung der ukrainischen
landes bedeutet die nato greift ein also
gewalt muss man auch sagen ist legitim
streitkräfte stärken kann damit sie
das lob bisschen herrlicher gemeint ist
absolut und dazu schreibt martin bach
die wenn sie der widerstehen wollen dann
ukraine sind sie nicht beunruhigt der
und das macht auch zum teil eindruck bei
an uns an die westlichen gesellschaften
gibt es noch ein zdf spezial und eine
wir bislang geliefert habe also vor
madrid
ukrainischen soldaten kommen hier hin
geführt hat sondern geführt wurde und
ein machtvolles signal auf das
den ukrainern
erfolg hat als dass die unions fraktion
wie wäre denn deine einschätzung ist
streitkräfte aus sehen kann was bedeutet
demokratien als geschlossen und als
zäsur in der haltung der spd-geführten
der länder auf der usa
unions fraktionschef friedrich merz und
weitere kapazitäten für die luftabwehr
diesen fixkosten kampf fortführen können
als in den vergangenen tagen er hat ja
einsatz von nuklearwaffen ist gefährlich
das was er macht ist im grunde genommen
es ist nicht so dass das völkerrecht
das kann ich ihnen tatsächlich nicht
aber sie hat auch mehrfach im chat
ihr ziel zu erreichen nämlich ihr land
brauchen sie daneben der luftabwehr auch
wirklich spannende doku über den
regierung zur lieferung schwerer waffen
da gibt es hier keine diskussionen
allen dingen ehemals sowjetisches
auf youtube.de spd stand in der kritik
ihren antrag womöglich fallen lassen
gesagt hat er hat sich noch nicht
außenminister dass putin
handlungsfähig wahrgenommen werden auch
das wird eine hoheitliche entscheidung
das ist ein problem das man jetzt mit so
dass jetzt so eine art befreiungsschlag
den menschen barbara schreibt auf
außenminister lawrow fia in dem
verbietet diese waffen einzusetzen wir
eine frage von der new york times
das feuer wieder anzünden dass wir in
und nicht hilfreich niemand kann einen
auf dem us-luftwaffenstützpunkt
geliefert werden kanada hat heute viel
auch die deutsche gleich als also die
sagen es gibt auch die frage ob es geht
das für uns für unsere
material wird irgendwann komplett
endgültig committee hat noch nicht
angesprochen worden auch die logistik
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky die
die möglichkeit tatsächlich ihre
die union legt den finger in die wunde
wird und dem der regierung
gewesen ist das jetzt der schritt
darüber naja wie viel kann man denn
und absolut der spd und ihrer
youtube ich hoffe deutschland macht
interview gestern abend schon mit einem
in dem wettbewerb mit china dem die usa
solchen krieg gewinnen niemand will
noch munition gibt für den gp da gibt es
ramstein so ist es kommt dann diese
einer lieferung nicht mal eben aus der
verteidigungsindustrie
von hamm aggressor wieder zu befreien
deutsche den deutschen kurs wechselt
dürfen ländern die angegriffen werden zu
zerschossen seien nicht mehr einsetzbar
der ukraine sein und die nato
endgültig gesagt ja wir werden in dem
ausbildung stattfinden das heißt
mehr zugesagt dass auch gepanzerte
deutschland in debatte haben ob das
soldaten zu schützen das heißt sie
keinen fehler ich habe angst vor einem
ich euch einfach sehr sehr ans herz
da außenminister gestern haben sie
vielleicht oder auch nicht sondern da
russlandpolitik das ist ja noch mal ein
einen solchen atomkrieg
wenn man bedenkt dass die spd-spitze das
gewesen oder wird die kritik am
sein dann wird es nur noch gehen dass
denn die der bedarf für munition und
gleich als allererstes erwähnt hat aber
richtig ist aufwendig den dritten
welt schaffen kann wobei die
mechaniker müssen ausgebildet werden an
antrag der koalition zustimmen aber er
gewissen säbeln rasseln reagiert hat
brauchen gepanzerte fahrzeuge sie
es gibt ja eine frage ist es nicht wenig
krieg absolut nachvollziehbar hermeling
legen möchte und empfehlen kann nachts
ganz viele menschen jetzt daran arbeiten
unruhiger wird und sich noch bedrohter
thema für sich und da kann ich auch
nachricht dass jetzt doch schweres gerät
zunächst einmal die regierung beiden als
fahrzeuge geliefert werden und das ist
hilfe kommen nicht nur mit waffen wir
weltkrieg auslösen damit etc auf der
gibt es die ganz klare aussage wenn die
man west gewiss material nachliefert und
das hinzukriegen es gibt relativ viele
zögerlichen handelns weitergehen ja ich
eben auch die anderen länder genannt die
verteidigungsministerin ja gerade eben
hält die tür offen das ist ein
brauchen auch lang reichweite artillerie
gerne darauf hinweisen dass wir gerade
würdest du sagen dass es gelungen zu
dürften es sogar mit soldaten wir tun es
gesagt dass die ziele der us in ukraine
den fahrzeugen alles das kann man zum
ich habe noch eine letzte frage ich
geliefert werden soll ist das wirklich
fühlt und womöglich dann doch zu
nato angegriffen wird dann wird die nato
noch zu wochenbeginn
gut bis bald
sie angetreten ist eine viel größere
egal was wir tun wir müssen immer sehen
ein gewaltiger fortschritt und das
nachhaltig die ukraine am kampfsystem
hat sich bereit erklärt dem zuzustimmen
heute jedenfalls ihren kurs gewechselt
gestern dazu einen stream gemacht haben
diese diskussion würde ich mir heute
ausgeschlossen hat wenn man sieht dass
damit sie die anderen stellungen auch
gewissen teil parallel machen und man
waffensystemen ist gewaltig
in der pressekonferenz gesagt hat dass
zeigen es gibt viele länder die zusammen
seite der nato
bedeutung beigemessen hatte als russland
gebhard überall auf der welt noch
hätte gerne noch ihre einschätzung eine
grundprinzip der nato auch hier möchte
nicht weil wir eben fürchten dann
habe den vorredner gehört der das jahr
haben und er sah so zufrieden aus wie er
atomwaffen greift
wenn die ampel noch ein paar
auszubilden die bereits ausgemustert
so bewusst gewähltes timing oder war
zurückschlagen angemessen also da gibt
wünschen und nicht erst in zwei oder
hat keiner ein interesse daran auch
daran bestehen dass russland geschwächt
verstärkt sich jeden tag und ich würdige
dass ein gleichgewicht gewahrt wird und
erreichen können alles das ist das was
verteilt wir haben auch eine sehr fähige
deutschland da keine alleingänge macht
den ihr auf youtube auf facebook und
der bundeskanzler in der letzten woche
in meier hat noch eine frage an dich du
ein bisschen skeptisch sieht ich würde
ich nicht spekulieren was passieren wird
woche nach beginn der militärischen
tatsächlich in eine größere
drei wochen wenn es wieder eine akute
muss sich auch immer vorstellen am ende
nun was nun da das übergreifen auf
kleinigkeiten geändert wenn sie
wird könnten sie mal genau erläutern was
worden sind
stehen
klar so wie es im moment ist so wie wir
irgend einen roten knopf zu drücken und
schon sagen es ist für die
dass wir den richtigen ansatz meldungen
und immer eng in zusammenhang und
rüstungsindustrie die in der lage ist
auseinandersetzung mit russland rhein
natürlich auf zettel erfreute ich auch
die worte schwere waffen nicht in den
es hier keine keine zweifel und und
alle staaten die hier weitere
die ukraine fordert und wo westliche
überhaupt noch einmal redet mit ihm also
ich glaube ganz fest
bedrohung und als gute bedarf gibt es
wir müssen natürlich auch an unseren
weißt dass das in deutschland seit
großoffensive im osten
damit einen krieg auszulösen und ich
also die frage der nachhaltigkeit hat
auch sein kann weil es den amerikanern
den zweifelsfalle aus zwei panzern einen
sie unter dieser schwächung verstehen
werden diese systeme jetzt unmittelbar
bundesregierung der versuch eines
gezogen zu werden das möchte niemand
moldau angeht wir haben hier
ja ich denke schon dass es gilt ja auch
ich glaube man kann davon ausgehen dass
gerne noch weiter anschauen könnt da
mund nehmen wollte dann ist es eine
dastehen können wir in dieses treffen
wochen eine große diskussion darüber
partner ja zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
keinen moment dass das zögerns in den
dass
eigenen bedarf denken und an den bedarf
wäre gut quasi eine strategische
aber die unterstützung der ukraine ist
was wollen sie schwächen und wie können
glaube das gleiche ist eigentlich auch
befreiungsschlages was deutschland jetzt
am donnerstag der ganz große
nichts mit dem alter zu tun nachhaltig
ja
auf dieser konferenz in ramstein
und in diese gespräche nicht reingehen
bereits hin zu liefern deutschland
haben wir einige fragen dazu beantwortet
zu machen wenn ich das mal so salopp
gibt wie zögerlich mann handelt im bezug
ordentliche kehrtwende der
unterstützung zu sagen aber wir haben
perspektive auf die unterstützung der
sie denn da den erfolg messen ich glaube
künftig wenn möglich die ukraine erneut
im krieg gebraucht das heißt sie werden
als einer der punkte bei denen der
also das timing spielt natürlich eine
ja ja schwer einzuschätzen also wir
unserer verbündeten und partnern aber
ist die frage wie viel material davon
sagen darf aber natürlich das material
unterstützt hier mit ausbildung von
bisherigen aussagen
bundesregierung
in moskau der fall aber natürlich
parteienstreit hier in berlin zwischen
keine zeit zu verlieren heute die
wie jetzt plötzlich also bis gestern war
warum sich die sozialdemokraten in
zur sicherheitskonferenz in ramstein hat
vollkommen legitim und aus meiner sicht
ukraine einzunehmen
das dann vielleicht auch ein
nicht die soldatinnen und soldaten
es gab er in der pressekonferenz noch
daher sehen wir langsam aber sicher
endlich aber was man sich da auch vor
sehen natürlich erst mal was passiert
versuchen sie so viel beeinflussung wie
kommunikationsproblem der
der ampel und der größten
auch verantwortungs mäßig geboten und
werden nicht perfekt mit dem system
habe ich eigentlich in der hinterhand
hier sehen wir wenn ich richtig
auf waffenlieferungen und da fragt ihn
rolle und natürlich spielt drang steigen
dieser frage möglicherweise besonders
augen führen muss das ist jetzt
bewegung wie in den letzten wochen auch
us-verteidigungsminister lloyd austin
und kann ständig sozusagen nachgeliefert
eine frage zum nato-beitritt der ukraine
bundesregierung ich glaube ja
ist dass russland kräfte massiert hat
seien es wird aber auch nicht so
möglich hier im westen in unseren freien
diese wien heute diese geberkonferenz
oppositionsfraktion der union zu ende
wahrscheinlich nur eine zwischenlösung
informiert bin haben wir bilder dieses
schwer tun andreas ich schaue mal gerade
amtskollegen aus über 40 staaten
denn was sie sich vorstellen müssen ist
betrieben sein wie wir uns das im westen
sie kommen langsam voran es kann sein
wie sehr hat der ruf deutschlands im
dass deutschland mit unterstützt im
würden sie jetzt insgesamt sagen dass
tatsächlich dass das
bis man bessere und nachhaltigere lösung
gesellschaften zu machen wo sie das
eingeladen gerade erst war es denn in
und da hat verteidigungsminister austin
kommunikationsproblem viel größer ist
russland hat einen riesen arsenal an
flugabwehrkanonen panzer vom typ gepard
diese entscheidung jetzt doch schwere
politischen washington schaden genommen
was es im chat noch gibt
machen können weil unsere medien sind
vielleicht theoretisch mal vorgestellt
sein wird dass es also deutschland bei
geleitzug mit dem partner und ich sehe
dass russland dieses mal die leeren
für die ukraine hat das heißt also dass
ist dies ihr reparabel sind wir eine
als das lieferprobleme deutschland steht
haben einfach weil der krieg viele dinge
frei und strahlen solche dinge natürlich
kiew die usa haben deutlich ich möchte
waffen an die ukraine zu liefern nach
den großen parteien ein einheitliches
sich eigentlich ja sehr offen geäußert
gesehen vielleicht können sie uns
bei uns im chat dass das zumindest von
gelernt hat aus denen aus den letzten
aus das ist nicht verkehrt das ist sogar
die bis man im genom westliches material
ja l'oreal luke skywalker fragt auf
belastung innerhalb des nato bündnisses
erklären was kann dieses gerät
er hat ja gesagt dass es vor allem eine
bild abgibt nach außen in dieser krise
richtig wichtig ist dass wir dann sehr
weil wir ständig bremsen
einigen auch durchaus goutiert wird
und das ist ja schon mal was natürlich
wird der streit nicht zu ende sein
sowohl innerhalb der
koalitionsfraktionen gibt es weiter
kritik aber natürlich auch bei den
anderen oppositionsfraktionen außerhalb
der von cdu/csu also von der afg von der
linkspartei deswegen wird es weiter
diskussionen wird es weiter kritik geben
es wird auch schon weiter grund zur
kritik geben aber ich glaube mit dem
heutigen tag steht deutschland doch die
deutsche politik sagen wir mal etwas
geschlossen hatte als in den wochen
davor
und wir werden es weiter beobachten und
wir bleiben weiter drüber reden und
darüber berichten vielen dank andreas
kühlers aus dem hauptstadtstudio berlin
was gut ist und damit schalten wir
[Musik]
[Applaus]